me and him had a special bond a young
life stolen before it could even truly
start he had a lot of character and he
was funny david sanchez speaks about his
younger brother oscar as those who loved
him gathered to honor his life wednesday
he appreciates all the love that you
guys are coming out here to show the 16
year old was hit and killed by an rtc
bus here along boulder highway near
indios on tuesday night surveillance
video shows him riding his electric
scooter on the sidewalk seconds before
the crash i feel
very very sorry
i'm sorry it happened christina ekman
who works in the area calls this
situation devastating and all too common
oscar's death marking the
125th in metro's jurisdiction so far
this year the neighborhood needs to be
patrolled david and his family are
asking others to stay safe
and understand the absolute worst can
happen i just want the community to be
here and just to be aware as they do
their best to remember oscar his love
for life
and the happiness he brought to their
world he had a whole life ahead of him
he was only 16 years old and this was
only the beginning
police say oscar ran a red light here at
indios when he was hit the bus driver
stayed on scene and did not show any
signs of impairment if you would like to
help oscar's family with funeral
expenses we have a link to their go fund
me page on our website 8newsnow.com
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now